Traduttore: TEDx Milano Translators
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Stiamo tutti dicendo
che la consolidata massima
"Mors tua, vita mea"
è una delle più grosse idiozie
che la mente umana abbia mai partorito.
Madre Terra ci sta dicendo,
anzi ci sta urlando,
che ad occuparci
dell'ultimo, del più fragile,
del più minuto dei suoi esseri,
non stiamo facendo
un atto di bontà ed eroismo.
Stiamo soltanto perseguendo
il nostro bieco, cinico
e immediato interesse.
Questo vale per una questione
di cui si parla dandole un nome errato:
i migranti climatici.
Ne tratteremo dal punto di vista
del nostro bieco, immediato,
cinico interesse.
Solo che questo interesse
dobbiamo capirlo.
Vedete in questa diapositiva
qualcosa che vi è familiare,
si chiama Europa.
Ma avete mai riflettuto
sulla stranezza di questa idea?
Tutti i continenti sono delimitati
secondo delle barriere geofisiche.
Secondo questo stesso
criterio, noi siamo Asia.
Non esistiamo.
Eppure vogliamo essere un continente,
anzi il Vecchio Continente.
Che cos'è che ci caratterizza
come qualcosa di diverso dall'Asia?
Diremo: una cultura
che nella sua diversità
ha una certa unitarietà;
senza voler fare
stupidi discorsi di razza,
una certa omogeneità fisionomica.
Ma poi qual è la determinante
fondamentale di tutto questo?
Perché siamo unitari?
Beh, la determinante è il clima.
L'Europa è l'Europa,
con una sua identità particolare,
perché ha beneficiato
di una anomalia climatica.
E intorno a questa anomalia climatica
si è creato il nostro
congiunto di interessi.
Solo che le cose stanno cambiando.
Questa caratteristica
climatica dell'Europa -
sto super-semplificando,
ma in qualche modo è determinata
dall'essere stati soggetti all'influsso
dell'anticiclone delle Azzorre.
Che sta retrocedendo, lasciando il passo,
sempre di più, agli anticicloni africani.
Che cosa significa questo?
Significa che, se il clima
è stato così determinante
nel forgiare la nostra identità,
e i nostri interessi,
cambiando il clima cambiano anche questi.
Perdiamo la nostra identità europea?
No, a questa se ne aggiunge un'altra.
Noi entriamo, anche,
nella comunità di interessi
che sono governati
dall’anticiclone africano.
In questa prospettiva di interesse
possiamo cercare di capire
cosa significano per noi
quelle persone che sono
mandate via dalle loro terre
da un clima che cambia
e le rende meno generose.
Ma dobbiamo anche capire di cosa parliamo.
L'idea generale
è che quanto più si è poveri,
tanto più si è propensi a emigrare,
e questo non è vero.
I più poveri sono racchiusi
in quella che tecnicamente si chiama
la "trappola della povertà".
Hanno così poco,
la loro prospettiva
è di così corto raggio,
che a emigrare non ci pensano.
Il loro problema è trovare
la ciotola di riso fra due ore.
E solo quando si inizia ad avere
qualche sicurezza in più,
che si concepisce il viaggio
per andare lontano,
per migliorare il proprio stile di vita.
Ebbene, questi, coloro che hanno
un po' di base per concepire il viaggio,
almeno una piccola dose
di libera scelta di farlo,
sono i veri migranti.
E se gestiti bene possono anche avere
un ruolo positivo per sé stessi
e per chi li accoglie;
ma questo è un altro discorso.
Il problema è che il clima che cambia
incide sulle vite di quelli
che migrare non potrebbero.
Quelli che devono andarsene semplicemente
perché il campo si è disseccato.
Questi non sono migranti,
questi fanno parte
di movimenti forzati di popolazione.
E chi è preda di un movimento
forzato di popolazione
non è utile sé stesso,
non è utile a nessuno.
Perché è anche preda,
nella sua estrema fragilità,
dell'illegalità, dei traffici,
del terrorismo, del fanatismo.
Cosa fa il clima?
Siamo abituati a sentire
che il clima che cambia crea
dei fenomeni più estremi, più violenti
e quindi impatta anzitutto
sulla nostra fisiologia.
Ondate di calore mettono in difficoltà
le persone più anziane;
si stanno ampliando i cosiddetti areali,
cioè le aree d'incidenza
di alcune malattie infettive.
Poi sentiamo anche dire
che i fenomeni climatici violenti
fanno del male alle nostre infrastrutture.
Gli uragani che fanno
crollare i ponti, eccetera, eccetera.
Ma quasi nessuno parla
del vero effetto devastante
del clima che cambia.
Che cos'è l'effetto serra?
L'effetto serra è una porzione
di energia solare
che viene introitata dal nostro sistema
e non viene rispedita nello spazio.
È tanta!
La quantità è stata annunciata
in un'altra TED, una decina di anni fa,
da uno scienziato
forse anche un po' controverso,
ma comunque della NASA: James Hansen.
È l'equivalente dell'esplosione
di 400.000 bombe atomiche al giorno.
E in che cosa si trasforma questa energia
che non si incanala in delle strutture
che si sono formate nel corso di millenni?
Si trasforma in disordine,
si trasforma in imprevedibilità.
Lì dove il clima diventa imprevedibile,
le società hanno difficoltà
ad organizzarsi.
Se io sono un contadino
e non so quando pioverà,
non so quando semino.
Ma non è solo una questione rurale.
Se io sono l'amministratore
dell'acquedotto di Milano,
e non so se ci sarà neve o no,
ho dei grossi problemi a pianificare.
Ecco, se succede da noi,
nella misura in cui sta succedendo,
ancora riusciamo a rimediare.
Ma se succede a un contadino
del Burkina Faso,
lì la questione non è più economica.
Un mancato raccolto,
per un contadino della Valpadana,
può significare perdite economiche;
ma forse si è assicurato,
forse interviene la Regione.
Per il contadino del Burkina Faso
fa la differenza fra mandare
o non mandare i propri figli a scuola.
E allora diventa
un problema di diritti umani.
E capiamo come una persona
che è sottoposta a pressione
sulle sue prospettive di futuro,
sui diritti più fondamentali
della sua famiglia
diventa preda di migrazioni, di fanatismi,
di destabilizzazione di ogni tipo.
È qualcosa per il futuro?
Purtroppo no, sta già succedendo.
Sta già succedendo in zone
che sono caratterizzate
da un ecosistema fragile
che si sovrappone ad una società fragile.
Sta succedendo nelle isole,
che stanno urlando la loro disperazione.
Le Maldive stanno mettendo da parte
una porzione dei proventi del turismo
per comprare, in futuro, un'altra terra.
Sta succedendo nei delta dei fiumi,
che si stanno salinizzando.
Sta succedendo nell'Artico:
le popolazioni artiche
sono alla disperazione.
Gli manca tutto quello
che ha definito la loro cultura.
E si trasforma in alcolismo,
si trasforma in suicidi.
Sta succedendo nelle montagne,
particolarmente esposte;
e poi sta succedendo di fronte a noi.
Il posto dove sta succedendo
più massicciamente, al momento attuale,
è proprio di fronte a noi:
ci separa un breve tratto di mare.
L'Italia si distende
fra le due sponde del Mediterraneo
come se fosse un ponte.
Vi mostro una mappa della porzione
settentrionale dell'Africa.
È composta perlopiù di deserti
che sono stati deserti per lungo tempo.
All'interno di questi deserti,
come abbiamo ben capito questa mattina,
ci sono delle popolazioni
che hanno trovato un modo di vita
compatibile con quell’ecosistema
piuttosto avaro.
Solo che in questa zona
non c'è solo il deserto.
C'è anche una zona,
che grossomodo coincide col Sahel,
dove c'è la desertificazione.
Se noi mettiamo sul piatto della bilancia
la generosità di queste due aree,
il deserto e la desertificazione,
in termini obiettivi
l'area della desertificazione
è ancora un po' più generosa,
ancora un po' più ricca
che non quella del deserto.
Solo che nell'area della desertificazione
è venuta meno la certezza
dei cicli della natura.
C'è il disordine di un clima
che non è più regolato
e quindi non ci si può più organizzare.
Vi invito a osservare dove si trova
e notare che coincide
con l'area di concentrazione
della fame e dei conflitti,
con l'aria di concentrazione
delle dinamiche terroristiche,
con l'area di concentrazione
dei traffici illeciti di ogni tipo:
armi; denaro; droga; esseri umani.
E guardate un po' da dove vengono
9 su 10 di questi migranti,
che ci stanno mettendo un po' in crisi.
Se questa è la realtà, per il momento,
su cui l'Italia, nel suo ruolo
di primo protagonista,
stabilirà uno standard,
non dobbiamo pensare
che la cosa finisca qui.
Vi mostro due foto.
Una è una mappa.
Nella prima mappa, vedete la fascia
dell’Hindu Kush, Himalaya, e Pamir.
Queste ad un certo punto fonderanno.
Non ho il tempo di spiegare perché,
[ma] non fonderanno gradualmente,
in proporzione all'aumento
della temperatura.
Ci sarà, ad un certo punto, un collasso.
I ghiacciai di questa fascia,
ad un certo punto, crolleranno.
Ma a noi che siamo italiani
che cosa ce ne importa?
Be', il fatto è che ogni volta
che si perde un elemento
di questo meraviglioso equilibrio
che chiamiamo biosfera o ecosistema,
non si perde soltanto
la sua presenza e bellezza.
Si perde anche la sua funzione,
la funzione che svolge
nel mantenere l'equilibrio
di tutto il resto.
I ghiacciai svolgono molte funzioni:
una di queste ci interessa molto.
Sono i regolatori di un ordinato
deflusso a valle di acque.
Dai ghiacciai di questa fascia
si dipartono fiumi,
che irrigano piane ove sono stanziate
1.400.000.000 di persone.
Se i ghiacciai crollano, in questa zona,
che soprattutto a sud è monsonica,
la situazione delle valli
improvvisamente passa
da una in cui, durante la siccità,
il ghiacciaio sciogliendosi
fa arrivare l'acqua con i fiumi,
a una di disastrosa alternanza
di siccità e alluvioni.
Significa che va in tilt l'agricoltura,
le infrastrutture. E molto altro.
1.400.000 di persone.
Noi abbiamo iniziato ad avere problemi
con l'arrivo di circa 380.000 persone.
Sommiamo a tutto questo
che comunque le montagne
sono degli ecosistemi molto fragili,
dove abitano popolazioni molto fragili.
Eh, sì, ma sono piccole, sono lontane -
no no, sono il 22% delle terre emerse
e ci abitano 913 milioni di persone.
Se si mettono in moto quelle...
E poi c’è un'altra foto,
mostra una metropolitana allagata.
È a New York.
L’innalzamento dei mari
è una questione molto controversa,
non si capisce bene se sarà tanto o poco,
però ormai gli scienziati -
avrete sentito parlare
di un recente rapporto
del Panel delle Nazioni Unite -
considerano abbastanza plausibile l'idea
che aumenti di un metro e mezzo
entro la fine di questo secolo.
Beh, aggiungete che il 42%
della popolazione umana
è stanziata lungo le coste.
Se il mare si innalza di un metro e mezzo,
ci saranno delle aree sommerse,
ma non è tanto quello il problema.
È che entra in gioco il cuneo salino.
L'acqua salata entra
nelle terre, e le brucia.
I romani,
per assicurarsi che la città sconfitta
fosse completamente fuori gioco,
sporgevano sale sui campi.
E questo è l'effetto che farà.
Vedo dai visi che vi ho comunicato
una bella cappa di tristezza.
(Risate)
Tutto è perduto? No, possiamo risolverlo.
E possiamo risolverlo
nel nostro bieco, cinico,
immediato interesse.
Come?
Beh, ricordandoci
che siamo parte di un tutto.
Questo schema che vi mostro
è stato elaborato
dalla fondazione Barilla.
Mostra due piramidi:
la prima è molto nota,
è la piramide alimentare.
Ci indica in che proporzione dovremmo
nutrirci di ogni categoria di cibo
per essere in buona salute.
Quindi poca carne rossa,
un po' più di proteine da altre fonti
e via via, soprattutto: fibre;
vegetali; eccetera, eccetera.
Succede che se noi
affianchiamo questa piramide
alla piramide dell’impatto sull'ecosistema
della produzione
di ciascuna categoria di cibo,
coincidono in maniera quasi perfetta.
Cioè, tanto più un certo tipo di cibo -
consumato in eccesso,
non sono vegetariano -
fa male alla persona,
tanto più fa male all'ecosistema.
Accidenti, che coincidenza spettacolare
nel settore dell'alimentazione!
Solo che non è una coincidenza,
e non è solo nel settore
dell'alimentazione.
È un paradigma della nostra
relazione con l’ecosistema
e non c'è bisogno di andare
a scomodare saggezze ultraterrene.
È il frutto della coevoluzione.
È solo normale che noi
siamo in pieno benessere
quando ci poniamo in sintonia
con il sistema di cui siamo parte.
Se non mi credete, provate
a farvi un piccolo esercizio:
la vostra piramide
del trasporto individuale.
E noterete che quanto più
la vostra scelta di trasporto
giova alla vostra salute,
al vostro benessere integrale,
alla vostra socializzazione,
ai ritmi di vita,
tanto più diventa sostenibile.
E questo vale un po' in tutti i settori.
Ma perché vi sto dicendo questo?
Perché questo ci dà una pista.
Ci dà una regola:
ciò che fa veramente bene a te,
fa bene anche al tuo pianeta.
Passiamo dalla scoperta individuale
a quella globale, geostrategica.
Se l’Occidente, per magia,
decidesse di nutrirsi secondo la piramide,
non solo staremo un po' tutti meglio,
ma si scardinerebbe
la polarizzazione del mondo
fra un miliardo e mezzo di persone
che soffrono di patologie
per errata o eccessiva nutrizione,
e 814 milioni di persone
che soffrono la fame.
Cosa significa?
Significa che sostenibilità e benessere
diventano anche giustizia,
ridistribuzione.
Si liberano quelle risorse
che sono consumate in eccesso da alcuni,
e diventano disponibili per gli altri.
Con che potenza, l’ha calcolato
un professore di Piacenza.
Se ciascuno di coloro che sono iscritti
come patologicamente obesi,
nei servizi sanitari occidentali
si astenesse da un'unica lattina
di bibita gasata al giorno,
creerebbe risorse per nutrire
56 milioni di persone.
Quindi: il mio benessere individuale
diventa sostenibilità;
la sostenibilità diventa giustizia;
ma la giustizia diventa pace,
perché un mondo dove tutti i bambini
hanno accesso ad una nutrizione decente
è anche un mondo che prende un po' a calci
Boko Haram, ISIS, eccetera.
E quindi io vi propongo questa equazione,
l’equazione della terra.
Sembra un discorso molto individuale:
la mia scelta in armonia col pianeta.
ma è un discorso politico.
Possiamo applicare questo metodo.
Queste mezzelune che vedete
scavate nel terreno sono in Burkina Faso,
e sono un sistema
con cui possiamo recuperare
un ettaro di terreno desertificato a $130.
Facendo questo, che cosa facciamo?
Riattiviamo per l'agricoltura
questo terreno,
ma creiamo un pozzo di carbonio
straordinariamente efficiente,
perché la vegetazione rinasce.
Non solo: proteggiamo la biodiversità;
consolidiamo l'equilibrio idrico;
facciamo diminuire localmente il calore,
perché la vegetazione
fa diminuire il calore;
e riparte tutta l'attività,
il mercato, eccetera.
Cioè, noi scardiniamo
il meccanismo del fanatismo,
il meccanismo dei traffici umani,
il meccanismo delle guerre.
Non ci credete?
Questo è il risultato vero.
Se non lo facciamo, cosa facciamo?
Lasciamo questi paesi
in preda all’instabilità
e questo significa che loro
non possono più collaborare
a recuperare il clima.
Sono fuori dalla gara comune
per avere un clima
che ancora sia gestibile.
Ma se sono fuori dalla gara comune,
nessuno riesce ad avere
un clima gestibile per tutti,
perché questi paesi contribuiscono
con i loro territori
gestiti sostenibilmente.
Allora cosa succede?
Se noi li lasciamo in preda a sé stessi,
tutti quanti ci creiamo quel futuro
che la IPCC, il panel delle Nazioni Unite,
ci ha dipinto 4 giorni fa:
2040, la catastrofe.
È solo il nostro bieco interesse.
Dobbiamo occuparci
dei più piccoli e dei più poveri.
Grazie.
(Applausi)